are there coveted bug chasers like you
know there's bug chasers where people
want to get hiv
are there people that just want
coronavirus they're like i need it
i need to get covered just going to
walmart walking there are bug chasers
people that want to get hiv and you've
watched documentaries about this why do
they want to do it
i mean it's clearly like a
self-destructive thing right so they
they they i think it's truckers mostly
truckers
is like yeah want to get hiv i think so
i mean
truckers they don't have enough problems
self-driving cars elon musk
they just want to get aids that's how
bad it is the truckers want to get aids
because job security in this country is
so is that really who it is truckers
i imagine it's like glory hole guys at
truck stop bathrooms you know they they
pick up prostitutes and stuff
on the road it gets lonely some of those
guys imagination is so
dark and troubling even to me
that asking him to even just a simple
question
uh he goes down a a very dreary
and disturbing and he's creating this
reality where he's just lonely truckers
on the road
at glory halls that just want and now
why do they want
aids i don't understand i get lonely i
get trucker i get glory hole
i don't get aids i guess you just want
to die right it's like this sick like
i'm a
like people were like i'm a piss pig
like piss all over me and [ __ ] all over
me
like yeah give me give me all your
diseases that you have i'm a piece of
[ __ ]
you know who's is that are those the
truckers as well they're getting pissed
[ __ ] on some of them are pissed pigs and
you know now what is a piss pig
someone who wants you to piss on them
piss in their mouth they want to drink
piss you know they want to feel really
funny i feel like my attitude
about drinking piss has
always been is situational where it's
like i feel like
if it's appropriate to do it the time
you might want to taste a little bit
but then probably spit it out you're
open to it interesting
well i don't want if someone is hot
enough
if someone is good-looking enough they
can get you to do whatever they want
if someone is good looking enough they
could get me to how go to the
a holiday with my family that's true
you know what i so i think that if
somebody's really good looking says
piss in my i will get a piss in your
mouth you have to say okay
no [ __ ] is a different story
yes a really good looking person says i
want to [ __ ] on you
that is probably disturbing
because then you tell all your friends
like oh i [ __ ] this person they're
really hot and then they go wow yeah
how was it you go well
i got [ __ ] on and then it ruins the
story i would imagine right it ruins the
story
or people are people are more intrigued
it's odd how sexuality develops like
it's very strange
like i always thought i might not be gay
if women were more intelligent
is that true i always believe that
so if women had a little bit more up
here i would probably [ __ ] them
that's a joke we have many female fans
and that's an
ironic joke because people expect my
audience to be full of misogynist
and it's not it's full of sensitive
crying men
and and lovely women and that's what we
we have more women all the time all the
time all the time they're rolling in
here these ladies
the couples watch together the couple's
watch together
isn't that nice and as soon as
quarantine ends we know what happens to
those relationships